the 2014 u.s chess championships have
experienced some major shake-ups and
there are several key players who are
responsible
sam the spoiler shanklin played a
merciless game against tournament leader
varusa nakovian
and alexander the hitman lender man
plowed through daniel naraditsky to put
himself back on top with baruch nagobian
a lot still to be sorted out and it's
all live right now at the 2014 u.s chess
championship
hello and welcome to the 2014 u.s chess
championships and u.s women's
championships here in st louis the
capital of jazz in america
we are in the beautiful central west end
right across the street from the world
chess hall of fame at the satan with
chess club the club that gary caspara
who will be joining us later in the show
called the nicest test club in the world
and we are actually having our sixth
straight usgs championship as we see the
women today are taking a day off so the
u.s championship we've got godakamsky
and a cobian they are about to make
their moves this is going to be another
thrilling round um we always expect
excitement in the penultimate round i'm
jennifer shahady and i'm here with
grandmaster yasser sarah pleasure to be
with you jen again
let's take a look at the standings which
as we mentioned earlier really shook off
yesterday
we've got tied at the top of varus
nicolby and alexander lenderman both of
them have a lot of wins right this isn't
like a draw tournament right big scores
big wins
and neither of them we would expect it
to be in this position in the beginning
of the tournament right behind them
defending champion gotta kamsky another
surprise for dell also won five and a
half within striking distance the lowest
player in the field at that
that's right and we've got grandmaster
maurice ashley with us as usual and he
has some thoughts on that key match-up
of the day
well indeed jen it is the penultimate
round of the championships when that's
the case in any tournament players know
they've got to put their game face on
because they want to perform strong
today
in
in preparation for tomorrow's game and
this pairing a fantastic one for the
tournament you have varusian ocobian at
six points he was running away with it
with four wins in a row before getting
beaten badly yesterday by sam shanklin
and chasing him the four-time champ
godakomski on five and a half he needs
to put together probably a couple of
wins or at least a victory today to have
a chance if ocobian wins godikomski will
be mathematically eliminated from the
tournament sitting at five and a half
points and then in another key match-up
you have alexander lindenman playing
against a tail ender mackenzie mulder
who has not even won a game today alex
has been incredible winning three games
out of the first five league leading the
tournament initially then losing two
looking like he was flagging and then
back in business by winning two in a row
a win today would put him at a gorgeous
seven points as well and his situation
looks like he's sitting pretty he wants
a victory and this could be a chance at
the u.s championship and even a spot on
the olympic team so indeed a fighting
matchup today we see godakomski if he
has five and a half he wins it shows
that the tournament is anybody's
tournament at six and a half with
varusian chasing him at six with one
round to go and the tail ender josh
friedal he's the lowest rated player in
the competition also sitting at five and
a half points a win against the very
dangerous sam shanklin would put him at
six and a half and then it's all to play
for in the last round so a lot of
potential scenarios we're analyzing
quite a few more of them including one
where there might be a six-way tie at
six and a half in the championships at
the end of it but those odds are
unlikely i don't know what the bookies
would say about them but certainly an
exciting round coming up today at the
championships guys
definitely i see today as the showdown
and godakamski defending champion
really having to go we'll have to go all
out today if he wants to keep his
championship title let's take a look at
the opening in that game what has
happened the team said we've got some
kind of
it would appear very um
a dutch defense
and let me just uh take you well that's
cool that's not i mean that's not what
we expected we always expect dada to
choose from one of his two big standbys
right
which really goes to show that
uh gotta knew that he was gonna have to
mix it up get var out of his uh
preparation f7f5 is not
standard in gada's repertoire and shows
that he he's playing for a win well you
don't have to be a match genius but you
might have to be a chess genius to beat
varakovian would lack exactly certainly
gotta fit to the bill a big ass the
amazing thing is sometimes these guys
who are chess geniuses seem like they're
really bad at math
when they need to go all out they play
cautiously type of deal or yeah they're
just like a little they they don't like
uh they don't do the calculations really
fast like that's the thing though just
doesn't actually have a lot of math in
it does it no but it's more visual
spatial skills yeah so if you if you
want to call it math more geometry
not calculating that's right but in
terms of the cross table well you don't
need
yes you got to win so f7 f5 today uh by
gotta i mean it's a well-known defense
it's kind of considered a secondary
defense
you take a lot of risks by allowing your
opponent to build up a center
but f5 uh does have several uh um
positive attributes about it i
everybody likes to control the e4 square
and by playing f7 f5 early oftentimes it
leads to some kind of king side
initiative all right knight c3 oh pardon
me let me just oh what have i got yeah
there we go knight c3 uh by var a
secondary move
um
basically everybody has played c2 c4 in
this position
and knight oops i beg your pardon knight
c3 the idea behind knight c3 is to play
for a quick e2 e4
and gotta shut that down at once with
the move d7 d5 again controlling the e4
square now there's like the marshall
gambit
where you can go uh
for e4 anyway
but uh this
uh specific gambit that i have in mind
um
has really been worked out to a
situation that black fares well and
so
e4 early e4 immediately pardoned me
i wouldn't expect that move
here vara could play the move bishop g5
trying to provoke the move h7 h6 and
drop back with the bishop so that the
square g6 is weakened
bar's actually still thinking on this uh
third move right still thinking on well
actually i think he's actually no he
hasn't played bishop to f4 he played
bishop f4 immediately i like the move
bishop g5 with the idea of provoking h6
and then bishop f4 i like the idea of
weakening the square g6 but bishop f4
was verosian varsity well maybe choice
he also liked the dutch because he saw
how tentative var was and kind of the
massive time pressure you know he also
played the dutch in a game against
ludwig in the world cup and that was you
know those two game matches so he
probably didn't want to go into the
blitz playoff instead so he was kind of
playing they drew the first game yeah
it's important
yeah and then he wanted to win the game
win the match outright rather than to go
into playoffs so he played for a win
with black and won a dutch defense all
right
very nice against john ludwig hammer
who's come up before in the broadcast
because he's also
a good friend of sam jacqueline right
and had been his second as well as
working for magnus carlson as his second
we've got maurice with something from
speaking of the devil sam shanklin and
josh ferdell's game josh fidel doing
fantastically and sam also coming off a
win
something slightly strange is going on
in this game and uh just take a look and
you can come up with your theories
about it in this position actually let's
just go to the opening itself sam played
this move josh played this move d4 a
known pawn sacrifice in this position
after c takes d4 knight to b5 and the
threat to play knight to d6
wins back this pawn just about no matter
what so d5 dealing with the knight d6
check threat cd5 ed5 castles and knight
ge7 these moves were played very quickly
then after the move bishop f4
threatening the fork on c7
black simply castled and in this
position you expect maybe knight takes
on d4 maybe this night on b5 move like
queen d2
instead the strange move knight to c7
attacking the rook and after rook to b8
knight back to b5
now an odd sequence here of course rook
back to a8 a tacit offer of a draw
sam shanklin is in no place uh to
not repeat moves here he has to but josh
friedal is only a half a point out of
first and you would think you'd want to
win with the white pieces so is he
looking for a draw this early in the
competition well he's not even allowed
by the rules you're not supposed to take
a repetition in the opening he's
supposed to play to at least 30 moves
and it looks as though he has deviated
he's now played the move queen to d2 so
what was that little shuffle about maybe
gaining
a couple of moves on the clock this
early in the game you know let me get 30
seconds on increment very bizarre way to
begin a chess game here at the
championships guys well yeah i said i
was going to eat not my hat but josh
burdell's hat if you took a draw oh wow
no
white pieces in this tournament
standings that would be the most that
would be beyond like shameful that would
just be bizarre it would be insane well
i mean a chance to win the national
championship uh you got to go for it how
many opportunities is josh going to have
coming into the tournament as the lowest
rated seated player
qualifying he didn't come through the
rating he won the u.s
open the united states open to get here
and here he has
an opportunity to win the
the national championship this is huge
uh making a repetition no i don't think
so i don't think so
but uh
anyway just to uh
should i bring that game up on my screen
jen or not sure
oops we should also check in on
lendermen when we get a chance oh let me
just let me check in on lendermen
because that is such a key game
in today's round now let me uh let me
point out again that we have a very
special guest coming in with us at
around 2 30 central standard time that's
3 30 east coast time gary kasparov will
be joining maurice to talk about the
future of chess america his feed a
presidential campaign and the games so
if you have any questions
hashtag u.s chess champs and
you might even be able to hear
the great legend answer it so exactly
you've got just a little bit of time but
be sure you don't go anywhere
and tell your friends
so what do we what do we have here in
the monar lenderman game is a very key
game for the standings well mack has
repeated the same opening
french defense or should even say
lenderman as what we saw in an earlier
game in the tournament between ramirez
as white alex linderman as black
and in that game
lenderman's preparation proved uh
fantastic as he won with the black
pieces against
uh
alejandro ramirez so we have a repeat of
that game
again just to remind knight f6 was what
was played by
lenderman
and we saw this trade so both players
still
early in their opening preparation here
and let's move on to
another game now walnuts have uh they've
had a lot of decisive results between
the two of them but i think as letterman
pointed out both of them are kind of
totally different players they're both
very young so
both um in their early 20s games from
2009 not necessarily that relevant right
both of them weren't even grandmasters
at the time exactly exactly so they've
really gained most of their style in
class in the last few years and
therefore lenderman said he wasn't
really thinking too much about their
previous battles
although but for the record uh mullner
won a game with white in the carol khan
defense
and he also won a game as black and the
grunfeld lenderman won one as white in
the bogo indian so those are some of the
more recent decisive games none of those
openings of course have appeared on the
board quite a mixture of openings and
defenses i might add okay so uh josh
riedel an outsider
doing his best
playing against
as marie said very dangerous opponent
sam shanklin i mean they used to both
live in the bay area of course yeah yeah
josh now you know each other quite well
yeah
so we see a symmetrical english opening
knight f3
e7 e6 so the idea from black's point of
view is he'd like to post his knight on
e7 and keep an eye on this d4 square for
a very common maneuver of moving the
knight on g8 to
take advantage of the d4 square josh was
having none of that and played d2 d4 as
mentioned by maurice a known opening
gambit and all of these moves have been
seen
many times bishop f4 castles knight c7
rook knight and now we have the move
queen d2 okay so the stage is set here
what white is trying to do is recapture
the pawn on d4 in the nicest ways first
he connects his rooks
and
leaves it open as to whether he's going
to play rook c1 or rook d1
now at first sight it might appear very
attractive to play the move queen b6 not
only does the queen
defend the pawn on d4 a very good thing
but it attack
it also attacks the knight
on b5
the knight on b5 must be protected and
you play a move like a2 a4
now once again it might appear very
attractive to try to attack this knight
and kick it away from the d4 pawn but
then
black gets into a little bit of trouble
in a variation like i'm showing where
the queen gets booted around eventually
the queen has to go
to
d uh b4 and after trades
white can pick up this knight on d4
put his bishop on d6 this is ideal for
white
so queen b6
an attractive looking move is actually
inaccurate
the move that i think
sam should really be giving a lot of
consideration to if he hasn't already
made his move is the move knight f5
defending the pawn on d4 and let me
again
just make sure i'm up to date with the
players because it does appear like sam
has made his choice
which was bishop g4 actually developing
a piece we'd go back to the situation
after queen d2 bishop g4 developing
his bishop attacking the knight on f3
threatening to capture it and then
maintain the pawn on d4 now josh had no
choice he did capture or recaptured the
pawn on d4 and queen b6
very natural looking move putting
pressure on the d4 knight
this bishop on g7 the fianchetto bishop
is an ambush eyeballing the pawn on b2
in conjunction with upon
the queen on on b6 attacking b2 feels
very
easy game at the moment that
black has already let us say equalize
the situation and doesn't have
that many problems
how do you think that he played this
opening i mean doesn't josh usually play
one e4
i
i think we're going to have to ask him i
don't know i can't even i mean of course
as we know we've mentioned it before and
a lot of other
a lot of great players mentioned
shankland as being or really well
prepared um i think i can't remember
where i read it but i think maybe it was
gustas in on chess24 who said like
chankland's known for his great
preparation yeah he works very hard on
his openings no question so perhaps that
was one of the reasons he's playing
something more offbeat but yeah we'll do
a little more thought into that um
another surprising opening as we
mentioned earlier it's not that
surprising because godakamsky has played
this dutch in uh a couple of recent
important games and including one in the
sink field cup yes he played this
against right but yes exactly um that
that that was a different line aronian
played with c4 knight c3 he didn't play
with the knight going in front of the c
pawn like aronia ocobian did right
but the game was a draw
and that was a tough tournament for
katakanski in the sink field cup he
came in last but he had a couple of
really memorable fights oh without
question all the games were really hard
fought uh just a little bit surprising
by uh got i'm taken aback by god as last
move after the move bishop f4 gotta play
e7 e6 preparing to develop this dark
squared bishop
either to b4 perhaps or more commonly d6
or e7 squares
and then after e2 e3
a formation known as the dutch stone
wall for the better part of 150 years is
to play c7 c6 these pawns
offer black a very solid grip in the
center now what about that light on c3
exactly normally we don't like our
knight on c3 in this type of position
for sure that's why uh c2 c4 and move
two is so common the knight on c3 feels
a little bit uncomfortable in front of
the c2 pawn and that's true for those of
you who are more beginner that's true
for a lot of d4 c4 openings but in the
dutch it's an exception it's a little
bit more popular because of those quick
e4 lines that you were discussing
exactly
now c7 c6 is the really uh
the most common move and the another
point behind the move c6 not only to
defend the d5 pawn but actually to stop
any knight prancing uh knight b5 knight
c7 for example like in the game between
josh and josh friedel and sam shanklin
so c7 c6 would be by far the most
expected move gada actually played a7 a6
this intimates that he's
that he's preparing to break into the
center with the move c7 c5 i don't like
this move a6 uh in this specific
position and the reason is because i
think g2 g4
is an excellent way
for white to attack the pawn on f5 i
played g2 g4 against alex your malinsky
in a u.s championship
many many years ago and got a very good
game as wide do you think jacobian's
aware of that game
or of this move
yeah i think he should be he certainly
uh has seen uh that oh but he hasn't
made it
quickly yes so certainly still aware of
the opening position
um
and actually god's results with f5 have
been quite strong i mean i mentioned the
win against hammer he also beat cosmo
with the dutch and the crow
gelfond
not such a big surprise maybe that he
chose the dutch for a critical round for
a key round yeah
more double edged because the problem
with the group even though it's
double-edged there are some lines where
white can
really simplify matters a lot some queen
trade lines absolutely a long long long
long line of forcing variations and
drawn
so
maybe god will felt that his chances if
he
and he needs to win
would not lie in the in the greenfield
because white can make a draw that's
right a wise well yeah
he saw how that worked out yesterday for
uh anna zadonski of course playing black
it makes it a lot harder um he also had
a win with black and not as quite as big
of a name but perhaps a big future name
with kate and troth and cayden is one of
the members of the rising stars program
which is a partnership between the
kasparov chess foundation and the st
louis chess club and of course we are
going to have gary kasparov on the show
um in the next hour and uh it'll be
interesting to hear his thoughts and
some of those rising stars which include
troph and sam savion in fact you see a
lot of their pictures on the wall here
jeffrey johnson
i wonder jeffrey and just to
explain a little bit more about what
that
that
i kind of think of them as all-stars
program is like first of all gary
himself hosts a summer camp about five
days long where all of these players in
the all-star program come to st louis
and have
a coaching sessions
the whole day also during the year
gary and his team will be sending
thoughts and ideas problems homework
homework for the kids to be working on
as well so
it's a
it's a very hands-on interactive program
and just the idea of working with gary
casparo i mean i would have just
thrilled me to to bits yeah these kids
are pretty
i mean lucky he doesn't even come close
young i don't think is actually part of
the program why isn't he is doing
amazingly lately and he was recently
just on the cover of chess life magazine
and this adorable photo where really
he's uh
he's in this uh he's
not his high school right he's like 11
right right
junior high winning school in front of
all his classmates with his medals and
trophies i'm sorry i stand corrected i
thought at the summer camp i was
actually here with gary and uh watched
him wrong i'll get confirmation but yeah
i know that kaden and sam are part of oh
that's clear and sarah chang from texas
yep
so really a great group of a great group
of kids um and yeah we'll be really
looking forward to hearing from gary you
can participate in the show too hashtag
u.s chess champs or comments at st louis
chessclub.org
and you can get a free membership to
chess.com juniors can receive a gold
membership to chesskid.com and perhaps
the biggest prize of the day on offer
you may get a question answered by gary
kasparov so
that would give you some good bragging
rights yeah get your questions ready
uh in our showdown in st louis game here
between ocobian and kamsky i'm just
looking you know it's a funny thing we
all tell
starting players that it's absolutely
vital to develop your pieces early
control the center get a safe king and
so forth and so on one of the things i
i'm looking at this position is white
and i'm not really attracted to white's
setup is if you look at the bishop on d3
it really isn't effective
this pawn on f5 blocks that diagonal the
pawn on a6 blocks that diagonal and
there are even ideas for black of
playing c5 c4 let me just make a bad
move for white for just a moment to show
how something could go very very wrong
very early
here in this game after the move bishop
b4 uh absolute pin against the the king
black has threatening to play knight e4
but a deeper
issue in the position for white is that
his light square bishop on e2 is really
ineffective so i'm not a big fan
of ocobian's early
opening play and i think black has
actually equalized and if i was forced
to choose whose position i like more i'd
rather play blacks
all right and you'd probably rather be
kamsky as well with those uh
those list of victims oh
world champion world cup champion
former world champion uh tasmanian
absolutely yeah wow that is a great
uh list of names to be sure also just to
continue the thought for a moment if you
were to capture capture castles knight
c6 again it looks to me that black's
position is more
is more flexible he's playing for e6 e5
this knight on c3 is misplaced white
would want to be able to counter in the
center with c2 c4 which would
necessitate
a knight retreat
from c3 to say e2 before you could play
c4 so goddess
opening choice
spot on in this key game
so somebody asked
at our hashtag u.s chess champs when
will grandmaster sarah juan start
twittering so we can follow his insights
all year long oh my
god he actually said tweeting
he was using yasserism
twittering we did have yasirisms earlier
on on an earlier show that was really
hilarious
twittering
i've never really gotten into the whole
facebook uh
um
net social network just
too much to do in life to really get
into it so it's probably not going to
happen anytime soon but if it is uh you
know probably it will be at em yes
something something like that
um
we did see in the game uh between josh
friedl and sam shanklin we did see josh
after the move queen b6 which i thought
was a very good move by the way just
connecting the rooks and setting up for
uh
pressure on the d4 and b2 pawn what josh
did is he he had to protect his knight
on c3 he dropped back with his bishop
uh to e3 menacing uh
discoveries against black's queen
and
we certainly love to take that bishop on
g7 with an i8 right that would be
positional crash so queen a6 was quick
queen a6 getting out of getting out of
the range of the dark squared bishop
putting pressure on the a2 pawn as well
as the e2 pawn and then we saw josh
trade nights with the move knight takes
c6 and again i just i'm
i'm thinking that the isolated pawn with
this nice bishop isn't that big a deal
after knight takes c6
i don't really think that white has any
opening advantage at all and i think
that black has equalized very easily
whereas
so so knight takes c6 you're not worried
about the pawn because just bishop takes
b2 and and where well after queen takes
d5 well first of all i could take this
pawn on b2 but i could also i have the
choice of queen takes
e2 as well just um equalizing the uh
pawn structure after queen taken and
threatening rook d8
and threatening queen b2 as well so i
don't uh this trait of queen takes d5
uh eliminates a weak slightly weak pawn
and black's pieces are more active
exactly so i just think that uh
black in this game has equalized early
and stands well experiment by white gone
wrong
yeah
yeah that's fair
uh whereas i was just wanted to say that
after b takes that season
then my interest in white's position
actually gets a little bit better i like
this bishop sitting over here on c5 i
like the idea of a knight coming to d4
and pressuring c6 and then after a move
like e2 e3 as well white gets in all of
those maneuvers he's going to have
a comfortable uh advantage so i think
sam's recaptured knight takes c6
is
uh
required you've been all about the
captures on c6 at the start of it right
yeah wow
you weren't happy with uh oh
oh that was already painful yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah bad that was really
what a wild game well weaker players i
mean amateur players make so many
mistakes when it comes to captures but
it seems that it's even true at the
highest level
why do you think that is well because
you're doing this constant judgment call
like when is a bishop better at night
when is the knight better than the
bishop when can we sacrifice the
exchange and you're constantly
constantly
trying to decipher
whose pieces are more active and whose
pieces are more passive and making those
trades
just a simple nuanced pawn move can
alter what you previously believed was
an active piece
and
it's almost like after each move you
have to
uh not necessarily recalculate but
recalibrate
your judgment as to which pieces are
better than the other ones oh that's a
great point i guess a lot of players
since you're known for being like such a
great strategic player a lot of players
when captures come into this position
they're all about tactics so they missed
some of those strategic things ideas and
all the different all the changes that
you mentioned in the position different
pieces opening and whatnot right and of
course that is kind of what happened in
the remira's game the move that was
played gained a tempo whereas the other
move was just
if you know if you ramirez is a great
player so if you took him and asked him
which structure he would prefer
without me without consideration i said
of course yeah of course you should play
v take c6 but in time pressure the
tactics kind of overtake you yeah and
you get sidetracked and sometimes really
it has happened to me that
i played a game i was either proud of or
unhappy with
really really really carefully analyzed
it and i said to myself was that really
me playing those moves i mean and i i
was just about to say although i think
lenderman is the most decisive player in
the tournament timor garriev has
certainly had his ups and downs and i
think he'll be scratching his head after
this event saying did i really play that
move in that game and that move in that
game unrecognizable in certain moments
i know
oh tell about uh timor's uh blindfold
ability there oh timor grave has done
some amazing blindfold feeds he's played
i think 30 boards at once here at the
casper 33 33 yeah it just it's
incredible to watch i mean it went from
about eight in the morning to about six
in the evening
and
uh keeping such a high level of
concentration for all of those hours
really really is you know you can't
believe what you're watching well the
thing is there's a lot of heated debate
whether
if you take a person and you train them
really really hard will they be able to
become a very strong chess player and i
think a lot of people think the answer
is yes but i'm not so sure if you train
somebody really really hard will they be
able to play 20
blindfold games simultaneously it might
be a special gift yeah what do you think
i i'm i mean you can do remarkable
things with training a well-trained mind
is it capable of unbelievable things
but
the blindfold you know 30 games
blindfold the idea that you could train
somebody to do that i find that really
hard to believe you it's some kind of
natural gift how your brain is wired you
know to be able to do that that's
yeah that's just uh phenomenal yeah
definitely a genius and uh what's going
on in our opening with the mackenzie
muller and alexander lenderman
i
we've kind of changed from a position
that almost looks like it's a sicilian
okay let's see yes well again this is a
repeating of the game between ramirez
and
lenderman from earlier in the tournament
in this position there's a number of
moves for white to play bishop b3 b2 b3
protecting the bishop queen e2 all
all have had lots of games bishop d3 was
played
and i believe the simple knight f6 is
what we're going to see from alex
and we've got a maurice with the game
that we haven't looked at yet today and
that's the one between ramirez and
robson
well jen just something struck my fancy
as i was looking at games first of all
the game that we saw with uh
friedel versus
shanklin and we saw from this position
in the opening
let me just get that away in the opening
we saw this setup after a few moves we
got to
this position after the move e6 was
played right so just freeze this
position in your mind if you will they
can blindfold chess both knights bishops
nice and feet and kettle and now switch
over let's switch over to the game
between
uh ramirez and robson and they were
following this exact same position up to
this point and it was the same position
on the board
uh after the move knight to c3 exact
same position now
already by now friedel had already
sacrificed his pawn against shanklin he
had already played this move knight to
b7 knight to c7
chasing the rook around so i started
wondering would they follow that path as
well but instead ramirez decided uh that
is robson decided to play the move e5
not allowing this pawn sacrifice at all
going into a totally different position
and in response to this aggressive pawn
move
an aggressive pawn move of his own did
ramirez which is move h4 looking to
tickle the blacks king's potential
residents on this side quite a committal
move as early as move six in the opening
yeah as all the classical principles how
do you explain to students these days
when players are pushing pawns on the
wing willy-nilly sacrificing pawns
making repetitious peace moves i mean
it's not like the old days i'm sure
capoblanca would be turning over in his
grave guys
yeah h4 would certainly be a move that
uh kappa would uh frown upon but ben
larson my personal chess hero would have
loved it that larson was a player who
loved to advance his his flank pawns as
a and h pawn just to disrupt his
opponent's uh comfort zone and obviously
in the game of alejandra ramirez that's
what he's trying to do against ray
robson he knows that ray just wants to
develop his knight to e7 and safety so
h5 just to disturb you know mix it up
same guy who always said said that a
knight on g6 is always bad
no uh
i was like that would fit well together
right that was one it was the guy who
said that and when i have a knight on f8
i never get made it all right well
especially if you're playing h4h5 and
cranking me yeah exactly exactly and we
are going to take a quick commercial
break we'll be right back with you for
more from the u.s champion tips here in
st louis
hi i'm lindsay part of the admissions
team here at paul mitchell the school st
louis
our campus is located on maryland plaza
right here in the gorgeous central west
end
i chose paul mitchell the school of st
louis because i visited other schools
and when i was at them i just felt like
the energy level wasn't the same it
wasn't as elevated as it is here
when i came here it just felt right
everybody looked great everybody had
such a great attitude the facility was
really clean and just so much more
advanced
technology can truly enhance your
education
when we brought in chromebooks and we
started using the smart tvs we really
tapped into the 21st century learner
being a student of palmetto is great
because the learning leaders are there
to guide you in the right direction they
give you the opportunity to make
decisions on your own they accept you
for who you are and they're always
welcome and honest and open
we have encouraged our guests to host
google reviews so far to date have over
100 reviews with an average rating of
4.5 stars
i like that this isn't just
for hair and beauty but it's also a
business college
you can learn hair you can brush it you
can tease that you can learn all of that
but to do business that's something that
really takes a whole different level of
education
whether we're in the classroom or at the
color bar we're always having a great
time at paul mitchell the school of st
louis
being a student paul mitchell gives you
a lot of opportunity for when you're
ready to get out into the real world
thank you for taking a sneak peek of our
campus and we can't wait for you to come
and see what a paul mitchell education
can do for you
welcome back to the 2014 us chess
championships look that hat is playing
on its own
where where joshua was at it's playing
on oh yeah
okay i was just going to say that
following up on the game between ramirez
and robson there's a nice trap
in the position that if you're not
familiar with it's a pattern worth
knowing which i'm just going to bring
this game up on our screen and we see
this move
h4 by white menacing a potential h5 and
what black usually responds with is h7h6
as did robson the idea is that in case
of h5
black bypasses this h pawn with the move
g5 fair enough
so what white does is play d2 d3
and then
oops i beg your pardon i'm going to take
that back for a second so what happened
after h6 is white
alejandra played d3 and then what
happens is say knight e7
bishop d2 castles and all of black's
moves have been very natural
white plays the move queen c1 gift meet
upon on h6 black's king
is induced to go king h7 protecting the
pawn and this is a trap
that a lot of players on the black side
have fallen for
h4h5 threatening to capture on h6 as
well as g6 black plays the move g5 and
suddenly bam
bishop sacrifice bishop takes on g5
h takes g5 knight takes g5 check
oh dear where are you going to go with
your king well if we go to h6 it's in
it's pinning itself so
right exactly walking in
and if you go for example to g8 then the
move h6 bishop drops back to h8
and you've got potentials of that knight
in six and queen eighteen
king goes over queen check king goes
over
and is this a rover position i think
this could be a rover position
not sure
i was also thinking of perhaps oh i
wanted to try to get my bishop into the
game as well but the scene was faster
well with bishop e4 these are traps that
black
just to go back to the initial pattern
this bishop takes g5 h takes g5 knight
takes g5 these have been very very
severe attacks for the black player so
playing natural moves
like
uh from
the game position just a moment
playing natural moves oops i want to go
to the game position can get you into
trouble again the way we got that
variation was bishop d2
castles queen c1 king h7 and the move h5
black has actually put his king
right into a scorching attack so ray has
got to be careful and let's go back to
our key game of the round
um
varujian ocobian he actually has played
that variation that i actually looked at
a moment ago where i said i didn't like
his play
uh white's play with his bishop on d3
that he was going to have to do
something you liked the more aggressive
g4 earlier absolutely because i think
that basically with this move white is
playing for c2 c4 and essentially what i
see white is trying to do is
equalize the position
i don't see and you don't and as white
of course that's not what should be on
tap of course not um we have more
comments coming in at our hashtag u.s
chess champs um mark twick of course
from the week in chat and we can chat
marth crowther who's also a great
tweeter he's always
got all the information for you on major
tournaments and major prs so
definitely follow him for information he
says that i always think of leonid
stein's 1-0 smith's love russian team
championship tournament from 1972 when
people talk about early h-pawn pushes
see i said you told him he had a lot of
information off his sleeve absolutely um
we also had a question yesterday that i
wanted to kind of add to um somebody was
asking about the measures we have
against cheating at the same level
and i was talking about how strict they
are i also just read an article that's
going to be coming out in chess life
magazine in a few weeks
about and cheating algorithm by ken
reagan right
and it you know tries to study the moves
and compare the rating you know about
this algorithm right absolutely yeah
it's kind of a snooper software to uh
analyze games and to see how often moves
compare
with chess engines
and whether
you're whether
a player's rating would justify a large
number of moves being similar so the
idea of ken software is to really put
the kibosh on somebody uh cheating only
just for a little while not not simply
cheating in the entire game right you
might say oh i've got to mix up my moves
a little bit but if somebody is cheating
at uh
periods of the game is what ken is
trying to also
stop right and it sounds like you really
need a large sample size in order to
analyze all this data the more data you
have the the easier yeah
the system would work and there's a
really in-depth story on that in the
june chess life magazine so take a look
out for that that's by howard godowski
yeah and by the way just a shout out to
ken professor
ken regan played in my first
u.s junior championship together in
memphis tennessee back in 1976 john
fedorowitz nick defermien michael road
jonathan tisdale
it was a great great tournament
basically everybody in the event titled
mark diesen was the winner went on to
become the world junior champion in that
particular year and there's another
famous uh ken rogoff who's a grandma ken
who's now a grand master ken rogoff and
uh he actually just was in the
mainstream press he wrote an article
about
um the bubble bursting in china it kind
of compared his
chess likes the interviewer compared his
chess career and his thoughts on
china and economics so it's really kind
of fascinating i encourage you to check
that out
and ken of course is uh
is a professor of economics harvard
international money fund um
chief economist
and uh
chess grand master of course
and uh one of my favorite quotes from
the article is i'm very addicted to
chess i still think about it ken says
even though he has only played a handful
of games in 30 years i'm trying to check
it i'm not thinking about it right now
he adds making me think that really he
is
yeah no no i mean once you're bitten by
the chess bug you always have an
interest in what's going on and i know
ken has had an exceptionally busy life
but what little time he has he still
tries to
tries to stay informed let's say i just
was noticing that sam shanklin
had recaptured with the knight and josh
riedel uh played a very common move when
your opponent's king is
when your opponent's king is castled
nicely hidden behind a fianchetto bishop
the bishop on g7 not only
provides nice defend defense to the
black king it also acts as an active
piece in the position attacking the move
the pawn b2 josh played
a common uh movement bishop h6 in order
to produ force a trade uh bishops just
to point boldly point out the obvious in
case of a trade black is really inviting
a very dangerous
piece over to towards his king and you
couldn't sam would not certainly would
not capture this pawn on e2 thinking
he's just snapping upon because after
night knight g5 with the threat of queen
takes h7 checkmate and then the hat
really would be lucky and that would be
a really lucky hat that is not what
sam's going to do no invitation don't
invite your opponent's queen to come
over for a visit near your king now we
do have a special guest with us a friend
of mine and a friend of many of the
chess players actually he's from las
vegas he works for caesars so
millionaire chess hope and obviously is
also part of the caesars umbrella plan
at hollywood absolutely elliot lou one
of the interesting things about elliott
is you know he played in the u.s
championship some years ago when it was
san diego in san diego
and he's natively from san diego and i
have i mean i think his friends are
constantly making fun of him but
apparently there was an elliot lou day
proclaimed in san diego because of his
success there sweet how many test
players have a day named after them
that happened to me
well no way yeah in seattle seattle
washington of course what was the day
your birthday no it was yasser sarajuan
chest day and i got uh
i got proclamated by the senate in in
olympia as well
one day all right well here he is
elliott lou he's an fm and he is with
maurice ashley
thanks jen with fm ellie lou first of
all thanks and welcome to the show thank
you for having me
elliot uh lou day in san diego how was
that you were all of what 16 i was 16
yeah how did that feel like it was the
biggest surprise in my life to date
probably came out of nowhere did not
expect it and uh
as the officer said i mean they give you
this whole proclamation process and you
go into city hall and they they read
this thing in front of everybody and
yeah that's what happened any friends
made fun of you after that yeah of
course they had to
it was like the big shot mr elliott
so you have a lot of friends here at the
championships tell us a bit about how
you've been following their progress
yeah so i mean i'm here to basically
support them um to begin with uh but my
main friends in the in the event are
alejandra ramirez tata veper homiem
alyssa malikina mac mullener so i'm just
here you know supporting them i've
always i've always been following them
alejandra had an amazing result last
year and uh yeah so that's it
indeed um you've been looking at some of
the games as well so far have you seen
anything that's caught your attention so
i guess currently in this round uh the
icobian kamsky game is actually
following
um a game between boris kelton and
hikaru nakamura i forget exactly what
year that was and i forget the outcome
also but uh
ben and robert were discussing it across
the way
a heavyweight game for the championship
so the way okobian's going right now
you also mentioned that you've been
studying different scoring systems and
how this a different sort of scoring
system a soccer style scoring system
would affect the standings in the
championship right so a really
interesting thing i realized was if you
actually use the uh the system where you
get three points for a win one for a
draw and zero for a loss like they've
been experimenting with and a lot of the
international events there actually
would not be a tie
not only atop the leaderboard but among
the top four players so if you do the
three one zero system alex lenderman
would actually be in clear first with 17
points versia coping would be in clear
second with 16 points josh friedel would
be in clear third with 14 points and
actually godokamsky would be in fourth
with 13 points so that would definitely
mix things up a little bit now is that
fair who knows but it's certainly
interesting to see how that system would
actually affect the the results and
maybe influence the style of play also
absolutely because that system rewards
wins absolutely yep and i guess as part
of the caesars family you guys like to
see winning and losing as opposed to all
these draws that's what it's all about
absolutely i agree with you uh the
millionaire chess open is going to be
held at planet hollywood very excited
organizing that how's the caesar family
feeling about that uh we're all excited
uh you know i'm i work directly with the
property seeing as how our entire
organization or
we own it we own the property i'm
friends with
the uh the senior leaders of the
property also and we're excited to have
it uh over in october and uh i am not
actually registered yet but i might as
well announce it now i will be playing
um thank you thank you appreciate it so
breaking news breaking news yeah so i i
definitely will be playing i i hope it
really generates the type of publicity
and gets the amount of players that we
hope to see and uh it's right next door
to where i live actually so it's very
convenient very convenient no airfare no
hotel exactly what happens if you win
though do you have to uh
return them to winning
part of the thesis family interesting
conflict of interest right maybe my uh
my bonus goes out the window or
something i i i don't really know but
indeed well
fm thanks so much for joining us on the
show thank you for having me
back to you guys
thank you maurice ashley with elliott
lou yeah nice interview uh
in my proclamation day so i had to go to
the senate olympia just as i was
explaining that they read you all this
stuff and so i made a small speech where
i congratulated the senate on their
brilliant decision i thought that was i
had to get in the last word
um
let's see what has
i didn't realize
that uh this was the position that we
have between ocobian and kamsky has
actually
been seen and indeed one of the games of
hikaru nakamura
was played in this fashion i'm not
really too sure what it is that
white is attracted to in this particular
position it's clear that white does want
to play the move c2 c4 one consideration
that gotta could have is to try to shut
down that operation with the move b
7b5
and after
a4 c4 trying oops the sorry mouse slip
trying to play c4
anyway and things could get a little bit
opened like this again
the good news for white is that he does
have a lot of pieces in play going back
to the position one of the things that i
would like to do if i were black in this
position as i'd like to play for the
move e7 e5 and i'd probably play a move
like queen d8
e7 to support this advance white could
stop the advance with 95 but then after
a trade i could play knight g4 kick out
the bishop and play e5 anyway so still
all to play for in this game all results
are possible but i do believe that god
has uh
made a good choice yeah made a good
choice in the opening and he stands well
so question if god kansky has such great
results with the dutch why don't you
think he plays it more often
i think he's suspicious of it
uh just
in his heart of hearts he knows that
he's taking a greater risk than when he
plays the slav and he said it so many
times himself he said he loves playing
the slav he likes the positions he gets
and he just feels that
he's more comfortable in those positions
the problem that he knows with the slav
is if that white wants he can really
balance the position with the
slav
exchange slot
very very hard to get winning chances as
black and that particular uh choice by
white so that's why he's mixing it up
with the dutch and you know also it
mixes in a lot of dutches here yeah but
he plays it with the leningrad system
with the with the fianchetto as opposed
to the stone wall and by the way
he uh caro's really been a trailblazer a
pioneer in that defense really brought a
lot of new ideas and really even even
inspired many other players to
to play it as well so everybody's
looking for something that they can play
against d4 exactly right exactly that
gives you that activity yeah yeah and
gives you counter-attacking
opportunities yeah
i'm just looking at lenderman's game
again we're still in the and
the depths of theory i was about to say
i'm not that inspired
by
the move uh
max move at g2 g3 normally speaking
you're not so happy with white opening
up this long diagonal that once you've
played the move g2 g3 that long diagonal
for the light squared bishop of black
becomes like a magnet for the bishop
equally
once you put your pawn on g3
black does have ideas of h5 and h4
battering uh the g3 pawn
far more common is if you're going to
play this particular system play a move
like h2h3 all right much more so
and also another way of defending this
pawn on h2 not necessarily recommended
you can bring out your queen to h5
knight f6 draw back with your queen on
h4 just trying to discourage black from
castling king king side but if you
encourage him too much to castle
queenside he may well do so and then
your queen's not looking uh very uh
clever on the h4 square but g2 g3
not
an inspired move by mac i don't like
that move knight f
6 c3 has been played and now i think
that
um
a key decision here for alex lenderman
does he want to go in for a line with b7
b6 bishop b
uh seven or bishop december
um
what do you what would you prefer i mean
we want to get that bishop to the long
diagonal eventually bishop to d7 might
lead to the same thing if we can remove
the knight on d4 precisely so if you for
let me just put some moves on the board
just to show how that might happen is we
were if we were to get to a position
like this
um boy it's not exactly the position i
want
you could play e5 and bishop c6 getting
the the bishop on this diagonal
if we start right away with the move
after c2 c3 if we start right away with
the move b7 b6
we're for sure getting our bishop on the
long diagonal without necessarily having
to play the tempo e 6 e5 so um
i would probably just play b7 b6 myself
put the bishop on
b7
and feel very confident yeah i like
block's position well that's because it
does look like a sicilian where somehow
the e4 pawn has been removed for say the
d6 pawn and that usually is a trait that
black is trying to achieve right exactly
and that g3 pawn leaves something to be
desired now we do have a sacrifice alert
in robson ramirez oh wonderful just a
pawn just a little guy
i live for those little guys just a
second
ray robson alejandro ramirez
i was
talking about a trap
and we see that bishop
knight ge7 was played bishop d2
a2 a3
basically alejandro has not committed
his king to the king side because he
wants to be able to play after black
castles that h5 bishop takes g5
sacrifice so a2 a3 is a faint
uh white wants to play b2 b4
and rey just allowed it
um
most players and for very very good
reasons play the move a7 a5
not permitting b2b before a5 does give
you that kind of swiss cheese feel
the square on b5 i know you like this
position for white i do i've played it
uh most of my life in fact
but i also
do think whether he likes it or not
loosening weakening the d5 square the
move a5 in my
experience
it's a necessary one necessary evil
necessary evil bishop e6 b4 and rey said
okay gift meet upon
all right in this position there are a
numerous approaches that white can take
the first is just kind of think about
the position as a kind of a benko gambit
where you've got these a7
pawns on a7 and b7 as a nice little
targets
one one idea is for example after queen
a4 check
here you've got a choice you could stick
your knight on c6 it's probably more
common to imagine that the knight would
go back yeah safer because that night
those nights are going to kind of get
jammed up together yeah exactly a little
bit
a little bit safer then for example
after castles castles
rook b
juan we get this nice
uh benko gambit uh play that i alluded
to the pawns on b7 and a7
are uh
constantly
being targeted
for by white
and the other thing that you might do
here by res white is play uh to
play the move rook b1
and to put immediate pressure provoke
the move a5 for just a moment let me
just put this move on
our position for just a moment so
imagine let's say a move as ridiculous
as it looks knight a2
knight takes a2 queen a for check knight
c6
queen takes a2 so now again it's looking
like a benko gambit situation but i've
provoked the move a5
and that's usually
good
it's good for the first player in this
particular case so uh i do i do like
white's compensation very much in either
case of rook b1 or queen a4
although this is one of the few games in
the tournament that's not likely to
determine the champion
no but it's still an interesting one
that we'll keep our eye on well as as
maurice was mentioning before we came on
the show uh you know we're just having a
little fun imagining all the
possibilities and the the one that
maurice discovered is that if every
single
uh result went as follows in the last
two rounds
extraordinarily enough we could have a
six-way tie for first
and we don't even want to
investigate what that might happen
because the odds of that well we'll ask
the guy from caesar's but it's probably
2000 to 1.
yeah the playoff will be pretty messy in
that case yeah and we'll be long and fun
yes
and let's just see uh again we haven't
followed that much
uh alex onishok
uh
has having a very very steady
performance got rocked
with a loss that's very
unexpected yeah in his experience he was
doing really well if alex had if that
result had been changed well alex might
have been one of the people we would be
talking about
dania also disappointed with the outcome
of yesterday's games today these two
players with four and a half points are
playing each other
just a pair of knights have been traded
um
looks like a fairly balanced game
but that doesn't mean that there's not a
lot of play as well
meanwhile our tournament leader of
arunachovian well our tournament
co-leader was lenderman
um
he's just uh lost his bishop on d3
so gotta cancel he's played the maneuver
night before and knight takes d3
and now the structure of the position
has changed a bit because white has
recaptured with the c pawn so you know
we've been talking about exchanges and
the pros and cons strategically how do
you feel about this exchange of night
for bishop i'm sure that var will be
very very pleased
uh that
the knight went on this little tour here
back a moment ago
gotta play the night before a3
the knight captures on d3 pawn captures
d3 we're talking about white playing the
move c2 c4 trying to get a share of the
center now with the pawn capturing on
with the pawn capture on d3
what black what white is trying to do is
control these two squares the dark
squares in the center of the board d4
and the e5
var is in this is a very comfortable
position for var i would expect him to
play moves like rook c1 95 knight d5 and
the light squared bishop
i like the two bishops as well but this
is not a position where the light square
bishop really shines
and i think that god has chances of
winning this exact position really took
a nose dive i don't like that decision
you don't like that
maneuver at all no i don't
and by the way just in that game with
robson
ramirez did play the move rook b1 a7 a5
was played and again i'm not saying that
knight a2 is the only move but i just
wanted to say once again that knight a2
knight takes a2 queen a2 queen a4 check
is the type of position why i like this
pawn sacrifice for white i feel that
strategically it's very easy for white
to play this pawn on b7 is weak there's
bishop on g2 standing in ambush white's
play is castles rook b5 rook b1
double and treble on against the b7 pawn
and black is thrown on the defensive
that's right and how are we doing with
lenderman yes
they're still in the early
stage we were talking about this move g3
not liking it and uh
lenderman has he made a move so yes
after
g3 knight f6
kane castle you were debating the pros
and cons of b6 and bishop d7 but instead
he played bishop to e7 didn't he no he
castled in this moment
that was his move and i'm
oh there's a couple more blues right and
uh again if you wanted to keep the
option open of h5 that's why you didn't
even like castling yes well several
things i wanted to keep the option of
castles long castles short and even
though even just keeping it
unclear and not not
necessarily committing myself with the
move castle so i thought that this would
have been a more enterprising
idea
for alex he didn't choose this line
instead he went for
let us say
solid chess he castled bishop g5 he did
not want to see the doubling of his
pawns on the king's side alex dropped
back with the move bishop e7 protecting
his knight and basically saying okay i'm
i've got a solid position
this particular position by the way i
must say i have a slight preference for
white so it's really
really topsy-turvy here for you a little
bit yeah
so are you still are you still trying to
play the move b6 i mean the thing is
when the bishop was on d6 b5 would have
led to a possibility if bishop takes b5
correct although i don't know if that
would have been that great anyway after
takes g3 right whereas now that's not in
the position but it still doesn't look
like a great move because it could be a
target unless you can meet a4 with
potential b4 so b6 or b5 what would you
pick or neither well probably neither
because at the moment i'm a little bit
concerned that if i played the move b7
b6 or b7 b5 weakening the square
only because of the move bishop f4 when
the black bishop was on d6 i didn't have
to worry about bishop f4 now the queen
is actually
it's a rather awkward hit let us say for
example bishop d6 loses a pawn a nifty
little tactic that we all should know
about
the old discovered check
black's queen
unprotected black's king is in a check
white wins
black's queen
so after
a move like
bishop b7 b6 bishop f4 if you play a
move like queen d7 for example uh looks
like a very normal natural move
i have a a different type of cheapo in
the position
i'll pull my bishop back so i want to go
bishop g2 if you go bishop b7 i want to
go knight knight f5 and thanks
to my rook on e7 my rook on e1 attacking
the e7 bishop
this works out favorably for
white yes we can grovel on and not
actually lose any material but
yeah you'll lose the two bishops it's a
pull it's a pull for white so at the
moment uh
alex has a solid position so does mulner
um
we'll see how that game uh develops
you have a question uh from james
backley he asks to the hashtag u.s chess
champs what book had the most lasting
impression for you when you began to
learn how to play chess yasser now i
know the answer in advance it's got to
be my system right no not even close
we just have a little bit of a running
joke yes there's not for those of you
who haven't listened to every show of
ours shame on you first of all you're
right secondly yasser is not the biggest
fan of ninja [ __ ] not even close uh
turgid
is a repulsive or words that come to
mind no the really really wonderful
books and they are truly classics i mean
i it was those were books i read once
and twice and thrice and with each time
that i was reading them i was gaining
100 points and getting more insights
than when i had when i originally read
them and i speak of uh the two-volume
collection of the best games of
alexander alekhine all right those those
two books were just amazing for me and
again i i i guess i started reading them
when i was like 1400
and i was like wow just whole new worlds
opened up to me then i was about maybe
1800 bored had nothing to do read them
again i had the feeling i was reading
them for the first time because i really
had this idea that i saw more i
understood more then i read him again as
maybe an a expert master and i go did i
ever read these books before i mean it's
just amazing how much was in those books
and it's so hard to read a textbook it
takes a lot right because every page is
so dense yeah but in his particular case
the variations that he was showing it
was just wild another book that had i
from that
experience i really really like games
collections books i really looked for
that like to be kyle towels as well oh
just over that mic i think that was
maurice's favorite my two favorite yeah
i remember him you being asked this
question in another broadcast and you
liked me kyle towel right totally love
mikhail tao i remember my friend uh leon
monroe and i back in brooklyn
uh gee back in the day bringing back
memories when we would sit down and we'd
look over tile games and we saw these
sacrifices that were just miracles the
guy's just donating pieces like
anytime he felt like it i remember later
reading he said a funny joke he said
according to latvian rules knights can't
go backwards so if you attack my knight
i'm just gonna have to sack it
and so that's why he'd always put his
knights on d5 b5 e6 f5 f5 just majestic
sacrifices like a just just entering a
fairy tale almost when you went over
toss games but i also remember the two
volume collection of alakine's uh yessir
and they made a very deep impression as
well this guy was a beast just ripping
people apart in his games and those were
absolutely two of my favorite players
coming up well first of all michael tau
one of my favorite authors just
wonderful authors very funny guy his
1960 book on his world championship
match with
um michael bod vinnick
is basically the best chess book ever
not just in the top 10 and not just in
the top five and not just in the top
three but 1960s just phenomenal book if
you have not read that book you cannot
claim yourself to be a chess player my
60 memorable games by bobby fischer the
paul cares
oh it's just fantastic bobby was just
great and uh and now the rescue books
are very popular i'm i used to read
those books i mean they were they're
very difficult very very different kind
of gives you a sense of a better version
of yourself rather okay
because it kind of respect the end game
book's not as as quite as complicated it
seems like that can reach all levels
right the end game manual yeah but it
was of all the books i've ever read it
was the games collection books i just i
love any new ones so they're my great
predecessors you must love that oh
wonderful
kudos to gary
and i believe i've heard magnus carlsen
say in an interview that he used to pour
over those books and
that one of the things he disagrees with
a lot of members of the modern
generation is that classics aren't
important right so he thinks classics
are aborted and just and he got some of
his introduction to that via gary and
just a quick correction basically he
said his uh the book that really made a
big impression on him was the game
collection of
vladimir kramnik okay that vladimir
kramnik's
best game magnus carlson said that book
just like wow that opened up his eyes so
he was putting vladimir kramnik really
really high a wonderful compliment to
vladimir and doubtlessly true it was a
great book too again
game collections i love them chess
players are running after the latest
opening
book ridiculous ridiculous waste of your
money
game collections are fantastic and if i
may add another game collection actually
two i remember reading over bought vinix
games collections
now another one is popping in my head as
well petrosian of all people i'm i
consider myself a more sacrificial kind
of dynamic player but boy petrossian
taught me so much about positional chess
i loved going over his games just the
nuances the fine nuances in his best
games collection and finally
no book uh
really has the kind of dynamism well
certainly alakins and tiles but in a
more modern style than the test of time
by gary kasparov that one i had dog
eared and actually got him to sign it
too so that's like one of my treasured
books in my collection speaking of uh
gary coming up he was definitely one of
my heroes watching his style of play
i actually uh went to a book signing
with gary kasparov and my great
predecessors and my copy of i guess it
was volume one or two it was very uh
there were some coffee stains used shall
we say i was a little embarrassed and he
was like wow you're ready
exactly
i went to a supernational tournament in
nashville
and uh
i was signing
for
children and young adults and one little
boy he must have been six seven
he brought me this play-winning chess
copy i am telling you i've never seen a
book in worse shape in my life i mean
his dog must have been chewing on this
book and i signed the book and
he walked away with a smile and his dad
uh came up to me and he said you know
he's read that book a million times i
said it sure looked like it i mean it
feels good as an author to see your book
you know mangled because you know it's
not just sitting on a shelf doing
nothing so that was a very good feeling
i think my worst experience as signing
somebody's copy of chess [ __ ] women in
the ultimate intellectual sport that was
my first book
they gave it to me and i opened it up to
sign it and it said to
the marshall it's it said to the library
right thank you for hosting my book
event
so they're trying to get me to resign a
book that they had gotten from the
library
oh
very cool very cool and uh what's the
so whoever asked that question um yeah
thank you for giving us a lot of
materials that's gotta get that's gotta
win a diamond membership doesn't it come
on you know chess.com diamond membership
you got a lot of mileage out of that yes
players love uh
we love talking about books too by the
way and all the books we read and had
big influences in our lives and one
thing that really struck me as a writer
writing is a big passion of mine is that
uh when daniel naradiski's mom came on
the show and was interviewed by maurice
on mother's day she said that her son
who's just a magnificent chess player
but also a very talented writer asked
when he was really young how do i become
an author right and i just think that a
lot of people have a passion for
the chess book and the writing oh
definitely definitely and a lot of a lot
of people who don't even study writing
just because they read so many chess
books they become good writers like
bobby fisher was a fantastic writer and
you know he pretty much just studied
chess right right that was enough that
was enough
but the thing i really liked about
bobby's writing is
he didn't
couch things and niceties he was a very
direct he's just very direct right now
this just is a bad move you know it
should never have been considered i
can't believe this you know it's like
damn
no niceties no flowerly language just
direct hemi ray yes crows right yes
exactly
we've got maurice for some news on
okovia and kanski our big battle of the
day
by the way i loved nimzovich sorry yes
but i thought that book was very
illuminating
but something that i'm totally befuddled
by is the situation in the ocobian
komsky game
kamsky play this maneuver knight to b4
just back up for a second uh knight to
after 92 knight to b4
chasing this bishop and then the move a3
by kobion saying
if you want it take it
kamsky said i did want it and then after
bishop to d7 rook to c1 he's been
sitting here thinking about this
position
for quite some time because he has only
32 minutes left on his clock now i
wonder if i have that wrong because only
12 moves have been played he has to make
28 moves
from this position with 32 minutes
basically a minute
little over a minute a move with the
30-second increment to be sure but
what is going on this early in the game
meantime
okobian started with an hour and 30
minutes on his clock he now has an hour
and 25 minutes and 28 seconds that means
he's played all his moves in less than
five minutes now that's not a big shock
but
the shock is how much time kamsky has
spent getting this position in the
opening
what is he thinking about uh well now it
looks like he has moved but is is this
clock time right jen please check for me
because it looks crazy yeah it looks
right to me
wow i mean one in 18 for version of
cobian and gotta kamsky 38 minutes and
59 seconds that's just
that's just bizarre right right out of
the opening 12 moves in he's already in
some kind of time pressure uh not really
you don't feel it just yet but you make
five or six moves and all of a sudden
you're looking at your clock
how can i only have 25 minutes left and
then another five moves and suddenly
you're 12 15 minutes it doesn't seem to
make any sense that he's played this way
a huge misuse of his clock no question
about it and i think god
got a sense
that something went wrong something just
went wrong seriously if we go back to
this position
when he played this maneuver knight b4
to capture this bishop on d3 he probably
had a specific uh line in mind
and as he got closer and closer to this
position he suddenly realized oh dear
there were issues with the line he had
prepared bishop d7 rook c1 already we
can see uh troubles are brewing for
black
and they're very very
quick like for example if the bishop had
dropped him back bishop c7
bishop d6 would have been a positional
disaster
all of these wonderful dark squares the
knights are ready to jump rook is coming
to the c file so
he could have lost the game with the
move uh bishop c5 he did play the move
rooks he won rook c8 by the way
and again i'm just thinking that maybe
he
uh
he cracked and he missed uh moves like
either knight e5 queen b3 knight d4 all
of these moves are so easy and so
natural for var to play so
uncharacteristic positional slipper from
gadakam's game big time well it would be
interesting to see what kasparov thinks
about that and we are going to be back
after the break with the legendary gary
casparo so definitely don't go away
and we'll be back for more from the u.s
championship and u.s women's here in st
louis
so
hello and welcome back to our 2014 u.s
chess championship coverage here in st
louis
according to mark twick
that fisher fuller puzzle was the
easiest one that we've had on u.s chess
chad's coverage so far so
perhaps you had a chance to solve the
discovered attack knight at six check
and also get yourself something to eat
while we await our exciting interview we
have gary kasparov former world champion
and feed a presidential candidate
and he is with grandmaster maurice
ashley via skype he's actually in new
york city at the moment
thanks jen we do have gary kasparov on
the show first of all you could add a
lot of plaudits to his title of course
he has done so much for chess uh in so
many roles including the kasparov chess
foundation uh his work as an author uh a
commentator
definitely unparalleled in the history
of chess is scope and we'd like to
welcome gary kasparov welcome to the
show
okay thanks uh actually morris you're
also in new york
i am from the are you in new york right
now yeah no no you are not in new york
yeah i'm in new york now of course i'm
actually no i'm actually in st louis
right now
okay yes i'm at the championships at the
moment first of all gary every time i
look on chess base i see
i see you flying all over the world i
mean a presidential campaign is usually
in one country
even sports stars travel only in one
country but your frequent flyer miles
must be crazy you're all over the place
tell us about your work trying to be
president of the international chess
federation yeah i have to tell you that
you know every morning i wake up first
30 seconds i'm spending to understand
where i am
so that's that's
to figure it out that's a really big
accomplishment
so i had uh just the last campaign two
started in new york okay i ended in new
york and included four continents you
know africa asia australia and europe
that was tough so certain countries in
in
29 days
uh but you know it's a great experience
because i i can hear you know stories
firsthand i can learn about you know
the chess development or actual lack of
chess development in most of the
quarters in the world
and i can talk to people so it's just at
the end of the day if we want to change
the world of chess you know we want to
find energetic people on the ground that
are willing to to execute this change
i believe that the future of the game of
chess is not you know vertically
integrated system with people sitting in
new york moscow brussels athens
everywhere and telling others what to do
but more like the giant social network
and it means that we need people on the
ground we need energy from the ground
we need fresh ideas of how to organize
our world
gary one of our viewers or twitter
followers asked what specifically in the
united states do you feel should be done
in order to change chess here in this
country where it's not as popular as in
other parts of the world
look you know it's this what do you say
it's not popular you know naturally we
are you know talking about you know the
number of people who are registered in
federation but this number is is is
minuscule compared to the number of
people who are playing chess either on
on internet you know sanchez.com or you
know
for fun and uh my idea is that you know
the uh as you see the president would be
just to to introduce what i call
universal rating system to make sure
that every game played will be counted
within one rating system you know with
different uh ratio for classical rapid
and blizz games but to make sure that
you know federations will be able to
attract
uh hundreds of thousands not millions of
people who i think will be will be quite
happy to join the same the same rating
system as magnus carlson and by having
these numbers we can actually
demonstrate that chess is popular chess
is not you know the game that you know
is played in dark corners in cafe but
actually you know it could present uh
numbers that would be attractive to to
any any advertiser
gary
you spoke about magnus carlsen just now
one of our listeners also wanted to know
what your opinion was of this this great
champion i mean
certainly a young star you've worked
with them as a matter of fact what are
your thoughts about magnus
magnus is great so it's the if you may
call a chess player an asset this is the
best asset in in in in in
recent years that chess chess could have
and uh um magnus uh is very medio
friendly i mean i'm not talking about
you know his uh outstanding chess
abilities because as we we could see it
i know uh that that's the he plays chess
uh great chess but also he's fighting
spirit i mean he's just willingness to
concentrate and to to to push you know
to the to to to the limits you know in
every game i think it just it gained
reputation that is very important not
only for him as a world champion but
also for for the sport he represents and
i you know i believe that as i see the
president i could have you know i
couldn't have a better better
world champion to work with me to make
sure that the game of chess will
reach
reach the height it deserves to be
gary i don't know if you have a chance
or had a chance to look at some of the
games from the championship currently uh
ocobian is tied for first playing
against godakomsky actually i'm looking
and as we speak as we speak i'm looking
at the games oh so please give us your
insight into that particular game
uh komski seems to be in some time
pressure as we speak he took a bishop on
d3 earlier in the game we weren't sure
that was a wise decision what are your
your thoughts on this position
you know why is clearly better i mean
there's the
i mean i i believe you know in in in in
traditional chess values so the having
the the the big hole on e5 you know it
counts for something
uh and two bishops here are not as as
important because they they don't do not
have you know much to do and
white also has you know pawn on d3 which
is protects e4 square which is a limited
black knight so and d4 square also could
be used by the knight so probably that's
one of the one of the options now maybe
to either play now knight before or to
play 95 or to play uh i don't know hook
c3 so that many in my view there just
you know white can press with no risk
and it's um it's i mean it's highly
unpleasant position i think the reason
uh kamsky spends so much time and he
understands that you know it's uh white
can uh you know do whatever without any
any risk indeed an unpleasant position
for him
we've seen a lot of young players here
the championships doing quite well we
know you do a lot of work with young
players as well tell us about that the
young rising stars program that you've
developed oh yeah we have been working
you know thanks to new support from san
luis chess club you know the kasparovs
foundation has been involved in in
supporting um young chess players and
i'm doing you know twice a year regular
sessions with them plus we we have our
you know coaches you know like sasha
chernyan working with them on the
regular basis and okay we i think we had
results so it's the i mean just to
mention them samsung so uh so he's so
successful you know made you know
grandmaster norms and uh and just a
matter of time i believe and rating for
him just to to acquire title and uh you
know quite impressive also i think
caitlyn troth hasn't spoken his his
final word and uh
um we have few other you know uh um
you know young guys you know uh who are
just doing well so i'm
i'm
quite uh cautiously optimistic about
about um uh the success of
uh us
u.s chess because we we we saw enough
young players uh joining joining the the
pack
and uh um
lately you know the
u.s won number of uh of medals uh in uh
in uh world under 18 championships so
the recently the
gold and silver under 10
uh uh went to went to this country and
that's that's a clear demonstration that
the talent is is is available elsewhere
just about your
uh your desire and your determination to
find it
finally gary you are running for feed a
president
the the current incumbent is has been
there for a lot of years many people
want to know what do you think about
your chances to win this time around and
what are you going to offer that makes
it different
look you know
i mean anything will be different after
19 years of one person in the office
yeah but it's the the problem is that
you know the
uh even
being there 19 years you know this they
the the the current team has nothing to
offer and they don't even bother to
offer anything so it's all negative
campaigning without even trying to
address the important issues and just
all empty promises that people heard in
2006 especially 2010. so um i
build a network of kasparov foundations
around the world so it's it's in here in
in america it's in europe and brussels
in africa in johannesburg in asia
pacific in singapore and recently one
was opened in mexico city for a better
america uh so and we have been working
quite aggressively in pushing chess into
education and we succeeded uh we had
quite
considerable progress made
everywhere but especially in africa
where we have numerous countries where
our programs have been already
implemented on ground
and i succeeded in raising corporate
funding and also
private donations uh to make sure that
these programs can be uh
can be supported um and um i also have a
very clear vision of of reforming the
world of chess as i already mentioned
you know just to turn it from the you
know sort of vertical into the
horizontal uh structure
a giant social network that will uh that
will include components as education as
a higher technology and the social
networking element itself and i think
that you know at the end of the day the
game of chess needs sponsorship
balancing sponsorship there are no
corporate sponsors and the very fact
that match khalsa anand
was not yet awarded any any sponsorship
just shows better than anything else
total you know incapability of feeding
management to work with corporate world
well gary kasparov thank you so much for
joining us on the show
15 years champion
uh many tournaments won one of the
greatest players of all time and now
running for feed a president thanks for
joining us thank you very much thanks
okay bye-bye
jenny yaz
one of the greatest ever no question
about it you can go over his games over
and over again and get great joy from
the dynamic style that he showed as a
player which he's now showing as a
potential candidate or a candidate for
the president of the international chess
federation back to you guys
that's right and that election is going
to be uh upon us soon august august
during the uh chess olympiad in tromso
norway uh that was that will be where
uh the
election takes place and it'll be
exciting to see how gary fares
in this election
that's right and
we've also gotten some questions about
the olympic team somebody asked what is
our olympic team going to be composed of
hikaru nakamura will lead the team
godokamsky will be our second board our
third board will likely be alexander
onishok some issues regarding timor
garriev he may not have his travel
documents in time therefore we would
expect varujin okobian to be our fourth
player and our fifth player is up for
grabs ray robson sam shanklin
alex lenderman
myself that i've taken myself out of
contention uh uh to be the fifth board
however if alex lenderman
uh wins the u.s championship and that's
a secondary story
or josh friedel
those players would automatically be
given birth
to the team they will be team
members
i'm looking at the game between um
jacobian our co-leader with godakamsky
and i'm mesmerized by the position
because just a moment ago
i really thought that
varusian had an opportunity here he
could have played the enterprising move
queen b3 a move earlier going after the
pawn on b7
i suspect
that he
decided not to do this because of some
complications that may have occurred
after castles offering the pawn queen
takes b7
bishop b5 notice that white's queen is
trapped and if black could play the move
rook on f8 to f7 trapping the queen
black would be winning maybe this
dissuaded var from playing the line but
i was pursuing it still with the move
knight g5 not only preventing rook f7
but also threatening knight takes e6 and
this simply looked very very good
for white to my eyes so i thought that
queen b3 was a strong move and if black
had done something different like for
example queen b6 then i thought trading
queens and dropping the bishop in on the
d6 square followed by knight e5 was
going to place black in really great
positional difficulty so i thought
that
that was a severe test for gotta queen
b3 queen d2 was var's move and i have
seen from our webcams that more moves
have been played and i was just about to
say that in this position
the position that
before i started talking about the
previous possibility what we have here
is this bishop on f
4 by white
that's not doing too much whereas this
bishop on d
c 5 can cover some dark squares so i was
about to suggest a swapping operation
where
var could play rook takes c5 rook takes
c5 bishop d6 which is precisely what
happened
going after
white will win back his exchange but
what will be left are these two very
weak dark squares in the middle of the
board d4 and e5 if white could let's
just make a move for black for a moment
b7 b6 just as a move
if if white could establish authority
with knight e5
followed by f4 followed by knight d4
godda would be in the type of a
positional bind that he's famous for
getting his opponents in
not being victimized
by a really nice dark square bind so
i think that uh varuji nakobian and also
if you toss in the times as well
is more than happy with the outcome of
the opening in this game
and now there's been a big trades going
on in another one of our key games today
as well or an offering for a trade not
yet a trade but uh in our game or
lenderman where
lenderman you know our other co-leaders
he's also tied for the lead with various
negovian um
you were starting to like white you
started out by liking blacks and you
were starting to like white because
you didn't love um linderman's kind of
slow treatment with bishop to e7 but
right now there's an offer of queen
trades on the board
queen f3 was played queen c5 uh the
queen of them a little a little tickle
over on the bishop over here
uh the bishop was defended with move h4
not 100 sure i'm happy about that but
okay
eight bishop e3 threatening discoveries
against the queen
and then came queen d5 and
that just looks like a very nice
sicilian setup
uh for black uh i think that letterman's
doing very well in fact so you like
black again now yeah white might sleep
somewhere yeah so it's interesting that
you don't like the move h4 because we've
been lotting this move in a lot of other
other positions but you know of course
one of the problems is that it could
turn out to be more of a weakness and a
strength since there's no real target
with that pawn on h4 that's uh
absolutely and the square g4 is
potential
it could be potentially used by
black as well but that's not the real
issue the real issue is if we end up
doing something like a queen swap queen
takes d5 knight takes d5 our bishop ends
up having to drop back i really don't
like
allowing black the opportunity of uh
capturing the bishop we drop our bishop
back it looks to me like with this very
nice night sitting here parked in the
middle of the board uh move like bishop
f6 uh just it's a very comfortable
position for black i don't see any
issues
any reason why
mac would be pleased with this position
also you look at the pawn on h4 and you
go okay what exactly does it do there
not much of anything i'm afraid it's not
really an aggressive attacking move now
do you think that a draw is a positive
result for lender man in this game no
actually just quite the opposite i think
that
lenderman has to realize he's in a
situation where he's got the potential i
mean it's just in his grasp of capturing
uh the national title with it not only
the prize fund all the accolades the
rewards of being a u.s champion but also
being a member of the olympic team and
he's playing
a player in the field who
sorry to say is one of the tail enders
so real opportunity despite the fact
that he's black uh i think that his idea
coming into this game is that a win
uh
is needed
he does play version of kobe and in the
final round right scripted that better
also once again he will be white though
so that game is just going to be a real
thriller absolutely what happens in that
game yeah and then of course kamsky
playing for now uh so basically we we've
got our tournament leaders all playing
one another in the final round exactly
and i was just looking at the game
between josh and and sam as well that
looked to be a pretty even
uh fight going on there so josh ferdell
if he draws this game will have to play
with the win against gotta with black
not a fun task but god will probably be
playing for a win as well and maybe will
take more risk than usual absolutely
absolutely i mean i always felt
that when i whenever i was in a
situation playing for first in the u.s
championship i just felt
um
not a moral obligation to myself or to
the game i just said listen you know
like i've been given this opportunity to
play for a national championship i've
got to give it my absolute best and i
really didn't care if i was black or
white truly in those uh situations i
just wasn't
you know the the idea of winning the
national championship was the first
it was paramount in my mind right right
you would worry about it if your
opponent tried to play a super drawlist
line then it might occur to you but
before the game you were thinking win
win win
and it seems like seven and a half is
going to win this championship oh yeah
yeah that's yeah yeah
yeah seven
yeah no we were just talking about a
six-way tie at six and a half so i think
seven and seven and then he's gonna get
seven points okay well yeah somebody's
gonna get seven points that might be in
clear force but i i really do suspect
that we're
going in going to see playoffs in both
events the women's championships we know
the women have a rest day today of
course uh and in the overall
championship perhaps although i don't
know if lemon and a kobe and say they
both draw today right and then they play
each other six and a half each um
they have the chance to get that seven
and a half point score which will
probably just win clear yeah because
they're playing each other precisely
they don't draw the game they could
decide it amongst themselves yeah and uh
the prophetic
uh godakamsky we may be seeing a new u.s
champion this year we might indeed yeah
anybody want to
wager what their their odds are on that
maurice ashley what do you have for us
on okovi and kansky
well looking at this position i'm very
surprised by the way okobian handled
himself here because it seems as though
he's just
basically gifting godakomski the kind of
position ghada likes
before we had this position here in the
game and there's so many moves that he
could play now he could play for the c5
with rook c3 he could play for the e5
square but he decided that at this
moment the best thing to do would be to
play for the weakness of this bishop and
make it into a pure superiority of minor
pieces so he sacrificed here played the
move bishop d6 rook dropped back to c8
takes takes and then rook to c1 now he's
essentially saying this piece is going
to be the worst piece against these
knights
that seems odd to me as being enough to
beat godakomski you imagine that he can
make god a suffer for a long time with
his dark square weakness but if he's
just going to play on just the technique
of this bishop that's super refined
chess against a player like ghada
naturally god who likes having this
position himself with the white pieces
knowing that he has very little chance
of possibly winning might disturb
godakomski in this position because he
just knows he's worse he just knows i'm
clearly worse and this guy's got all to
play for how do i make something of this
position because the draw really puts a
damper on his chances of repeating as
champion so maybe that's what a cobia
knows he's played koski before he might
know exactly who he's playing against no
risk just play for the small edge and
see if you can make this guy maybe push
a little bit harder and then get a
chance to win against him or if not you
just run out of there with a good draw
guys
well i recall a
comment that magnus carlsen made about a
particular game
that he was playing
where he said
there's only two results possible either
i win or a draw and that is a success in
and of itself and that's the way a
cobian certainly approached this game
saying listen if i could get a winner or
draw
not lose
it's great so
um not a big surprise about the move
rook c1 but uh without that move rook c1
i was just going to say that black's
control of the c file is wonderful it's
a open c file but all the business
squares on the c file are currently
controlled i would have pers personally
i would have just jumped with my knight
to e5
brought my other knight to f4 and and to
default pardon me from d4 the knight on
d4 would control the c2
square all the business squares again
being covered and then with the move f2
f4 cement my control over the center be
and keep that rook trade in reserve you
know you never know you know
but uh 95 would have been my choice
jacobian uh
to quote maurice ultra solid with his
choice rook c1 and
the pieces that are coming off the board
and more importantly the piece that is
remaining on the board is the light
squared bishop and that will be the
um
the piece that uh ocobian wants to
dominate by the way guys i may add to
what you're saying please my first move
like yours was absolutely knight to e5
it's like that's why you traded off the
dark square bishops was to dominate when
i threw it into the computer it came up
with this crazy idea first let me
get the board right knight e5 and he
came up with this nutty idea what if we
sack a piece
which of course shocked me but his point
is after knight takes on d7 queen to d6
threatening maiden one because the rook
is still on f1 and threatening the
knight as well forcing you to play